so I'm going to share with you my
investment philosophy and it has to do
with 10ps which I'll share with you but
here's what I want you to be thinking
about this applies to me and my mind
during a great time during a horrible
time recession or regular time that's
just vanilla but it is important to keep
in mind during a time like this
recession inflation fear unemployment
worries about unemployment going up all
of these things being a mind there's
probably never been a time in the last
10 years more important for you to get
clear about your investment philosophy
then today so having said that let's get
into the first piece of the 10 piece
that we have in regards to investment
philosophy
number one p is people so why people why
not a stock why not a mutual fund I love
seeing a track record of a person that's
continuously building a strong
reputation that's getting results that
has a new idea and I'll say you know
what I'm gonna support him here's a
million here's a half a million he's a
hundred thousand here's fifty thousand
dollars by the way this applies to Big
names like Elon Musk who goes from you
know X to PayPal to Tesla to boring
company to not wanting to buy Twitter
doesn't matter people follow him because
he has a track record of getting results
the same way in a small Market of say
200 000 people in a small City there are
plenty of smaller elons who have a
reputation of keeping the reward getting
things done when they say they're going
to do it they do it people say how much
money you're trying to raise five
million two and a half million two
million I want to be a part of that
because I trust you so number one p is
people today's sponsor is Aura what Aura
does is protect you against identity
theft which today it is the fastest
growing crime in all of my America just
last year 1.5 million Americans
experience identity theft for you know
how much money ready not 1 billion not 5
billion not 10 billion 52 billion
dollars just last year every 14 seconds
somebody's identity is stolen which
means during this video four to five
people's identity will be stolen and the
reason why this is important to me is
I've been in the financial industry for
a long time Insurance Finance we spend a
lot of money every year to protect
against cyber security attacks just a
fun fact one of our employees Aaron went
on their website and he tested to see
how many times his identity had been
stolen his password over 40 times on the
dark web you may want to find out how
many times your identity has been stolen
so if you want to protect yourself from
the fastest growing crime in America
visit aura.com forward slash value
timing to start your 14-day trial one
more time Aura
aura.com forward slash valuetainment to
start your 14-day free trial with aura
try Aura free for two weeks to find that
if any of your personal information or
your family's personal information has
been compromised number two p is
perpetual and what do I mean by
Perpetual anything that I know I have to
buy every month every week every day
Services products that are Perpetual I
will make the investment into that
because it's part of our life and you
can't just buy it one time and that's it
by the way Perpetual can mean a lot of
different things people don't go to a
chiropractor one time and it's over with
we don't just buy toothpaste one time
and it's over well you don't go to a
dentist and it's over with one time
that's it you don't go by toilet paper
one time and that said you clean up
you're good you don't buy certain things
that are over like a service a Netflix
type of a thing that I have to
continuously perpetually pay I look at
services that are Perpetual because it
gives me a certain stream of income on a
monthly basis so the second thing I look
at is Perpetual the next p is phenomenon
and what do I mean by phenomena
phenomenon is something that comes out
of nowhere let's just say hypothetically
and by by the way this is a very small
percentage of uh when I invest it's not
a big it's a smaller one because the
risk is always going to be higher this
could be collectible cards this could be
art for some it could be nfts or crypto
but it's anything that's a phenomenon
that just comes out of no one you say
you know what I'll put two percent into
this I'll put one percent into this I'll
put a small portion into this because
the upside is so massive but the risk is
also very high so your risk tolerance
got to be the right place to invest into
a phenomenon but every once in a while I
like to take a little bit of a risk with
certain products that is a phenomenon
that doesn't happen often with a big
upside fourth T is problems and what do
I mean by problems I like when I sit
down with somebody they come and they
say hey here's a problem here's how
we're solving it oh that's great
fantastic I'm happy with this this is a
great way I'm willing to do this what
could that behave you you're busy you
don't really want to go out there and go
get the food it's the middle of the
night you're at the house you've already
showered you put the kids down you don't
want to go get food right now Uber Eats
will bring you to no matter what you
want fan what a great idea ubereats
great GrubHub great all these types of
ideas that are solving a problem I'll
give you one from our own ourselves so
three four years ago I'm talking to one
of my lawyers and I have a seven minute
call with a lawyer after seven minute
call he sends me a 30 minute uh bill and
I call him I said listen it's not a big
number here but why am I paying you for
30 minutes we had a seven minute call he
said calls roll up I said what do you
mean he said seven automatically rolls
up to 30. so I said I overpay by 23
minutes he says that's how it works is I
can bring it down to 15 but typically
seven Rolls up I asked him this question
I said how can I pay you by the minute
interesting question fair question guess
what the lawyer said I've never been
asked that before I said Bingo if you've
never been asked that before but I'm
thinking about it myself I bet a lot of
other people don't want to pay by 30
minutes and roll up a lot of people
would like to pay by the minute what if
there was an app that I can pay to talk
to anybody by the minute a therapist a
doctor a investment person a lawyer a
person that's dealing with marriage a
person that's an phone service and
that's took a company public to we came
in here and we first looked to see if an
app like that exists we had a call with
one of the companies that had the app I
didn't feel comfortable with the founder
they wanted to sell us the company I
didn't buy it but we came out and we
said we're going to design it our own
way we called the app minect okay so
minute is m-i-n-n-e-c-t it's do you have
a minute to connect yes you can buy to
talk to me by the minute and we do a
15-minute FaceTime matter of fact we
have Tate on there we have you know Chas
palm and Terry on there we had a couple
of our guys Matt sapala interview Tate
for 15 minutes he took that video put it
on YouTube got a few hundred thousand
views we had a couple of guys do
interviews with certain influencers and
they talk to them they take that video
and they can do whatever they want
because you can pay by the minute so
that app if you do want to take
advantage of the app you can click on
the link below or somewhere above here
go download the app connect it solves a
problem you get to pay influencers and
experts by the minute not by the hour
fifth p is preventative and here's what
I mean by preventative too many times
like this is not exciting what I'm about
to tell you most people like oh my God
boring crime here let me skip to number
six hear me out before you go to number
six I've been in the insurance space for
21 years right my whole business has
prevented what's preventative you know
eventually we're all going to die we all
get taxed we're all going to die it's
going to happen no matter what so
insurance was preventative so I remember
one time when I went and raised 10
million dollars from one of my investors
they said we'll give you this 10 million
dollars but they asked a magical
question what if you die what are we
going to do with this I don't understand
the question you have I'm in the
insurance space he says yeah but we'd
like to buy keyman insurance that in
case you die we get the money back so no
problem totally makes sense that's a
preventative investment that you make to
protect your 10 million dollars so
preventative is a hedge so maybe for
instance I'm not telling you gold gold
is a form of a hedge you know there are
certain things you buy that's purely a
hedge I pay attention to preventative
Investments because it's a hedge against
the risk that you may be taking 6p is
patent and what do I mean by Patent a
lot of times creatives that are
constantly creating new products they
don't make good operators but they make
great products so if they create a great
product like I'll get a call from one of
my uh friends in the investment world
and say hey let me tell you about this
new Pac-Man this guy's got and here's
what he's doing XYZ this is what his
patent is and he's the only one he's
been working on this for three years
fantastic that's great however who's the
team around them well great question
here's what we have around them so if I
see a great pattern with the right team
around them I will entertain investing
into it only if the person with the
patent has the right Supporting Cast
around them because that person with the
patent very rarely does a person that
have a patent only have one most people
who have a patent they normally have I
have 43 patents I have 28 patents so
they get distracted a little bit but a
patent Creator inventor with a great
Supporting Cast I will consider
investing to those as well
P product here's what I mean by product
so the other day I'm talking to a friend
and he says hey Patrick let me share
with you this product what's the product
this product allows you to produce any
video content you're creating they
practice and get your voice down and
they're able to translate what you're
saying in 24 different languages I said
what this is 24 different languages you
got to be kidding me no
so immediately for only 7 500 we can do
this it's not what I'm thinking
immediately I'm like I got to talk to
the CEO why is there a round that can
get in what's their Supporting Cast what
are they doing so I set up a zoom with
them he helped me out I got on the zoom
with the CEO and the president and I sat
there and said what a fascinating
product and at that time was a great
time to go in and look at the investment
so again products to me is too many
times people see good product oh let me
buy this product no if you see a great
product that's a unique product go and
say how can I invest this is a product I
would use and I'm sure other people will
as well how can I get a thousand dollars
under five thousand dollars into ten
thousand dollars to invest not just
because it's a great product but because
I want to get involved and help the
company grow because I see this thing
being bigger than just the product that
I use on a regular basis so again look
at a product that you personally use
that you're excited about see if you can
potentially support the company as well
if it's got a big Vision a good
Supporting Cast 8p is predictable here's
what I mean by predictable anything I
can invest in this is not a high rate of
return this is not something that's
going to be astronomical this is not
something where you're going to go back
to your friends about that you see this
stock I bought or this nope it's very
predictable it gets the job done you
need it it's like a sports team that you
got 12 basketball players you need a
couple people that are predictable to
come and give you six minutes a game
eight minutes a game to relieve the
Superstar away but that person is not
going to help you win a championship but
it's predictable I will find some
predictable Investments that are maybe
an ETF maybe a mutual fund done in the
right way but some predictable
Investments that I know with a long
track record I will take a look at
predictable products 9p is property and
by the way I will tell you this is not a
big part of my portfolio but it is
something that I've gone through in the
last few years and I do it in my own way
and hopefully you can take whatever you
want out of this there's people that are
better experts in this than I am but I'm
going to give you mine I'm speaking to
my realtor and I'm talking to him about
hey what are your thoughts about real
estate economy coming down how much you
think it's going to come down basic
conversation conversations that I'm
having with this guy and he says here's
how you got to look at with real estate
when Real Estate takes a it any property
that's a regular property that's a
vanilla property those are the ones that
take a hit but a waterfront property you
can't build more water from property an
intercoastal property you can't build
more intercoastal properties a community
that's closest to the to the school that
every parent wants to send their kids to
well guess what you're not going to have
too many of those properties near the
school that everybody wants to send
their kids to a condo in an area that's
the hottest area of town that's got the
nightlife or whatever is going on
there's a limited amount a commercial
real estate property in an area that's
got a lot of foot traffic going on
that's always going to be in demand so
everything when it comes on to property
there's got to be a strategy behind it
if you're just winging it whether it's
land commercial residential rental it
doesn't matter multi-family everything
you do that do it with a strategy that
gives you the higher chance to get a
rate of return on it so ninth P property
last P but not least is priceless and
what do I mean by Priceless remember the
MasterCard commercial for everything
else there's MasterCard you know the
whole thing for this is this this is
that this is priceless when it comes up
to spending time with family our annual
rituals that we do I don't put a dollar
amount on it I want the best experience
because all year long we talk about it
Christmas parties I want the best
Christmas vacation that we have with the
family because we're going to talk about
it Summers travels entertaining our
guides it doesn't matter what it is when
it comes down to Priceless moments
you're forever going to remember that
whether it's you your peers your
co-workers your kids your spouse your
family all of it so 10th P last but not
least is investing in Priceless moments
memories that will last a lifetime so
having said
PDF to today's episode do us a favor
click on the link below subscribe to the
newsletter we'll send a PDF with one
pager and if you want to get more
content on money and you've never
watched a video how to double your money
click here to watch that video take care
everybody bye
[Music]